tonight is the return of lance mccullars
jr this is his first start off the
injured list and he had just the one
rehab start here's brock holt
this ball slowly hit correa in the shift
is going to flip with his glove and
makes the play to get brock holt
as he never uses the bare hand and flips
it to julie guriel for out number two
that was kind of nifty another change up
from lance as holt gets around it and
dribbles it towards
carlos whose momentum is going towards
first base
just decided to use that momentum and a
good glove work to flip that to julie
for that out
callow will be very patient the plate a
lot of strikeouts but also a lot of
walks this ball into the shift as jose
altuve will make the play to get gallow
for the final out of the inning
and after a half inning of play rangers
nothing astros coming up it's the
veteran
kyle gibson
33 years old and this will be his 13th
start of the year
no score bottom of the first inning 3-2
pitch and this one on the ground right
side of the infield and that'll be an
easy enough play to take care of
brantley
two gone well good start so far for kyle
a couple of ground outs as bregman
stands in 3-2
and this one
turned down the third baseline that's a
long throw for hole in time
and they get bregman at first what a
nice defensive play
by brock holt two in the inning here's
nate lowe
leading things off for the texas rangers
in the second inning
lance picks up his first strikeout
getting low with a changeup here's jason
martin former astros farmhand
swinging a mix
up you can go fastball change-up when
you have that kind of stuff
so the astros have a runner for chas
mccormick
02 and a strikeout swinging first strike
out of the night for gibson no score top
of the third and jose trevino pops the
first pitch by lance mccullough's junior
in the foul territory third base side
bregman over by the sidewall reaches
into the stance makes the catch almost
tumbles into the camera well but able to
get his cleats back onto the dirt nice
play by alex bregman got to the wall
and just leaned over that sidewall and
able to come up with that foul ball
his arm was just long enough and thank
goodness it was here because i don't
know if it would have been an away game
the fans will let him catch him
i see connor falefa grounded out his
first time up
swing and a miss
isaiah connor falefa goes down for the
third strikeout for lance two outs in
the inning
looked like it might have been the
cutter again getting on the side of it
creating that tight spin
good depth
here's brock holt
is it yet another ground ball for lance
mccullers
we'll continue on in the next half
inning as lance has a strong one-two
threading pop-up strikeout ground out
lance mccullers junior getting it done
so there are two outs and nobody on for
jose altuve they they get going it's
it's fun to watch ooh bouncer third holt
steps on the bag the second two on the
first
almost the triple play they'll get the
two outs however
going five to four
and that would have been a hoot this was
almost ideal for brock holt takes him to
the bag a little bit so he's able to
step on the bag go across to seoul i can
did you see watch how big nate lowe's
eyes get right here when he looks at the
umpire thinking did we get it
that was close too
so base runner to start the fourth
inning
this one hit hard and that's to the
alley in right field and that might be
enough trouble to get garcia all the way
in from first they wave him around third
base here comes the throw from correa
not in time
and a dolly scores from first base on
the gallow double rangers lead
one-nothing
with adolesce garcia on first base you
pretty much know that he is going to
score the second that ball is off the
bat there was a play at the plate
but he didn't have to even have to slide
he was standing up through it ranger's
in business for kyle this will be his
50th pitch of the ball game as he'll
face bregman 2-2
and that is strike 3 call
second strike out of the night for
gibson right at the bottom of the zone
2-2 pitch and there's a ground ball
shortstop
easy play for kinder philadelphia he's
got a handful of those today it's a one
two three fourth inning shut down inning
for kyle gibson four in the bucks
rangers one astros nothing lance is
going to leave this game with a bases
loaded here blake taylor has come on
they bring the lefty in to face
joey gallop the 3-0 and that's high ball
four and so the rangers take a
two-nothing lead on the bases loaded
walk to gallow
that ball hit to pretty deep left field
brantley going back he is near the
crawford box as he makes the play
right in front of the bullpen wall and
left center field he had to navigate the
crawford boxes out of town scoreboard
and makes the play for the final out of
the inning
and now here's mccormick who struck out
in the second oh for one in the ball
game
one two
and a strikeout swinging a mccormick
third strikeout for gibson tonight
looking a little bit late
throughout the entire course of
that at bat
3-1
and that one driven out to center field
but garcia quickly to his spot and the
inning is done now it's michael
brantley's turn 2-0 pitch this one off
of gibson karen's toward third and there
will be no flow
so he got a hard hit ground ball in the
infield but unfortunately they got a
piece of him and so the rangers can't
get the double play in fact they can't
get it out
i just hope that kyle's okay
looks like that one's stung a little bit
right on that right knee
on the outside of it the ash shows with
the base is loaded one out
for yuli guriel
that falls into center field garcia will
go back on it make the catch brantley
will tag and score easily bregman's
going to get the third rbi sac fly by
eule guerrielle it's now a two to one
rangers lead martin is over for three
tonight a couple of strikeouts or is he
trying to keep it right here payoff
pitch
ground ball right side altuve is there
martin retired final out of the inning
no runs a hit one man left on
rangers trying to put the finishing
touches on this one now josh spores
to pitch here in the ninth inning in a
one-run game for carlos correa this
would be a big spot for him he can keep
this game going
long fly ball deep right field correa
has tied it up
carlos correa
a two strike
two out home run five of the ninth to
keep the astros alive so two gone low
hit list so far tonight low been
swinging a pretty hot bat coming into
the game
and he shoots this one just off the
glove of bregman holt streaming around
third he comes to the play he'll score
and the rangers take a 3-2 lead in the
10th
base is loaded nobody out jose altive
the batter
altuve drives one deep to left field
martinez look at it that's gone a
walk-off slam jose altuve
a walk-off grand slam for jose altuve
wins it in the bottom half of the 10th
the astros are down to their final
strike
with two outs in the ninth and carlos
correa ties it and his double play
partner jose altuve wins it